today is also cinco de mayo oh i know
well it's interesting because i think we
might
have cinco de mayo a little off and
today we have a very special guest here
to help
celebrate cinco de mayo but also explain
to us
what the history of it is she is a
master chef winner
and a best-selling cookbook author and
the judge of the hit telemundo show
master chef latino please welcome chef
claudia sandoval
first of all it's cinco de mayo and a
lot of people think today is mexican
independence day
but they're incorrect is that right
please set everyone straight
absolutely uh mexican independence day
is actually a little further away it's
on september 16th really cinco de mayo
uh is dates back to of course cinco de
mayo 1862
and it's a great david and goliath story
because well
the mexican uh in puebla where
the battle of puebla happened were being
invaded by the french
and they actually stood up with like
this kind of tag group of
really unready uh unequipped
uh volunteer troops and they stood up
against them and in five
hours defeated them uh so really we're
celebrating
uh their ability to conquer it all today
it's
all about celebrating the mexican
culture you've got some great tips on
how we can do that right
absolutely you know one of them is
definitely learn and share that story
right i mean it's such an
amazing story that really could inspire
anyone right it's an against all odd
story
uh number two you know would be to go
out and support those like mexican
artists and museums
there's so many across the nation that
you can do
different tours with and last but not
least i mean
guys who doesn't love mexican food come
eat our food
go to your favorite mexican small
restaurant and support those small
restaurants that are really hurting
right now well speaking of chowing down
you sent us some treats from your new
bakery
oh my gosh what do we have here oh my
gosh well you've got our beautiful
seaside concha that looks like
a wave washing on to the shores of san
diego
and that's where your new bakery is
right yes
uh is a it means golden pig so you've
got a golden pig on there as well
it's a molasses-based pig with like a
little bit of cinnamon and nutmeg
it's like perfect the cup of coffee i
hope you love it
oh my gosh um cinnamon so
good oh my god oh wow i wanted to make
it a little judge with like all that
beautiful gold painting you know
i've got to know what this is because
there's a filling in there and so of
course
oh
mcdonald's apple pie and like the best
croissant ever
yes oh my god okay i'm so mad at you and
thankful for you at the same time oh my
god
i love to feed people so seeing those
happy faces like you are just filling my
heart right now like that is like
a compliment you can give a shot thank
you for information on claudia's bakery
and the businesses and artists museums
to which she speaks to support we want
you to go to our website at the
drewberrymoreshow.com where we will be
featuring some of claudia's
recommendations
in our small business gift guide thank
you claudia so much
[Music]
you